pas la parole est à monsieur bernard
perrut pour le groupe l'est républicain
monsieur le premier ministre
l'insee vient de publier la réalité de
l'emploi dans les treize nouvelles
régions et aucune est épargné par la
gravité du chômage avec des inégalités
fortes entre les territoires
les métropoles et les zones rurales et
intermédiaires la france voit rapidement
sortir d'une logique qui pénalise
d'emploi et nous attendons votre projet
de loi sur l'évolution du cadre du
travail
mais le président de la république a
d'ores et déjà annoncé une réforme a
minima qui ne touchera ni au contrat de
travail new smic ni à la durée légale du
travail à quoi servira-t-elle alors
qu'il ya urgence à réformer le droit du
travail pour lever les freins à l'emploi
et favoriser la compétitivité des
entreprises
elle vous prêt monsieur le premier
ministre a recentré le code du travail
sur les droits fondamentaux des
travailleurs et a renvoyé à l'entreprise
l'essentiel du dialogue social car vous
devez faire confiance aux organisations
syndicales de salariés et patronales
pour négocier et avancer etes-vous prêts
aussi à faire que le code du travail
permet à ceux qui n'ont pas d'emploi
d'en trouver un
grâce à plus de flexibilité et moins de
contraintes moins de rigidité
etes-vous prêts encore à ce que les
entreprises puissent avoir la liberté de
sortir des 35 heures est de s'adapter
aux réalités de leurs activités et
bénéficie d'exonérations de charges non
pas pour travailler moins mais pour
travailler plus etes-vous prêts monsieur
le premier ministre à modifier les
seuils sociaux dans les entreprises à
repenser les relations entre les
entreprises et les administrations
fondée sur un possible de confiance et
non de contrôle de défiance et de
sanctions monsieur le premier ministre
et salariés connaissent employeurs et
surtout les 5,7 millions de demandeurs
d'emploi vous jugeront nous vous
demandons de faire preuve de courage de
responsabilité d'ambition et nous
attendons vos réponses sur la
refondation de notre modèle social
la pologne est à madame la ministre du
travail de l'emploi de la formation
professionnelle et du dialogue social
madame myriam el khomri merci monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
députés
monsieur le député bernard perrut vous
n'êtes pas sans savoir que je
présenterai à l'issue des questions au
gouvernement
mes orientations au premier ministre et
cela fait suite au premier round de
concertation que j'ai menées avec les
partenaires sociaux
j'entamerai dans une seconde phase la
rédaction de la loi que je porterai en
2016 cette réforme sera je vous le dis
une réforme ambitieuse une réforme
ambitieuse qui réformera en profondeur
notre droit du travail
il nous faut j'en suis convaincu
faciliter l'accès et renforcer la
lisibilité de notre droit du travail
cela ne veut pas dire moins de droits
mais il faut assumer cette clarification
nécessaire au regard des mutations du
marché du travail aujourd'hui et
également pour favoriser la croissance
et l'emploi
ne vous en déplaise je le répète nous ne
toucherons pas aux 35 heures au smic au
cdi
nous souhaitons nous souhaitons
renforcer la négociation collective pour
permettre justement aux entreprises aux
salariés de de s'adapter aux besoins là
où ils sont le plus près c'est pourquoi
je travaille au renforcement de l'accord
de l'entreprise et au renforcement de
l'accord de branche qui est un sas
nécessaire notamment pour maintenir une
concurrence loyale pour les mêmes
entreprises d'un même secteur
vous me dites que vous êtes attachés aux
partenaires sociaux
je veux bien vous croire mais ce matin
en écoutant nicolas sarkozy permettez
moi d'en douter
il a d'ailleurs oublier que c'est lui
même qui a mis en oeuvre une réforme de
la représentativité des organisations
syndicales en 2008
alors l'objectif de ma réforme c'est
justement être au plus près du terrain
maintenir des droits des salariés mais
également faire mieux faire confiance à
l'intelligence collective
le dialogue social est pour nous
d'intérêt national merci madame la
ministre la parole et à monsieur juan
vinas